I wrote an article about
um the glamorizing of divorce like
I'd seen everywhere like the guardian
was talking about the joy of divorce
parties uh yeah the like Vogue was
talking about this Valentine's Day let's
hear it for divorce the New York Times
called divorce a radical Act of
self-love so I was seeing all of this I
was also researching gen Z's Mental
Health crisis and reading through all of
these reports and all of the reports
would talk about things like the economy
the climate crisis being reasons for Gen
Z's anxiety which just doesn't make
sense to me I don't think a 13 year old
cares more about the climate or the
economy than if their parents are
talking I think it's a lot of it is
close to home
um and I think there's this denial going
on about it because you know we've got
the most mentally ill generation on
record and family breakdown is just
barely mentioned even though we know
that having divorced parents leads to
you're more vulnerable to anxiety
depression Eating Disorders substance
abuse there was even a study that showed
that it has parental divorce has more of
a negative impact on educational
attainment than parental death so we
know that it has a huge impact and yet
it isn't factored into
um the Mental Health crisis and why
sorry Francis I just want to finish this
at this point
um why do you think that is forever
because I know that like in our day it
was you can't talk about the breakdown
of the family because you're demonizing
hard-working single moms that's the
argument right is that still the
argument or is there a different or is
it or is being like is every form of
family quote unquote they're all equally
valid now is is yeah I think it's a mix
of things I think
is just this idea in Modern Life that
everything should be should be fun and
easy
all the time and any kind of
responsibility is restrictive and
inconvenient and so I think a lot of
parents kind of lived by that they kind
of were conditioned by Society to think
you know the ultimate freedom is your
own happiness I think for some for some
marriages obviously there's reasons for
divorce but I think that was also
happening
um and I think now we're seeing the
consequences of that and I think a lot
of parents are still maybe in denial
about the impact that it's had because
it was something like they asked
Children of Divorce how it affected them
and parents four out of five parents
said that their children were fine with
it whereas literally 75 of the children
had had things like anxiety depression
Eating Disorders substance abuse it's a
hard thing to admit of course especially
if you if you felt that the divorce was
you know important or necessary or it
was genuinely you know people don't
always can't always keep it up but it's
just we've seen over the last 60 70
years that rate is skyrocketed in every
Western Society I think it's too close
to home for people because if you're
talking about it everyone knows someone
who's gone through a divorce or their
parents have or so it's really hard to
talk about and it's much easier to look
at things like the financial crash or
the climate whereas I think for young
people their world is their friends and
family it's who's close to them and I
think something like divorce makes much
more sense to me why you would feel
anxious than something far away like the
climate crisis
and what is what is your generous
relations attitude to Motherhood do do
the girls still want to get married do
they still believe in that married you
know having two kids a family or are
they kind of more seeking
careers and all of that path yeah well I
think it's half of women are now
childless by their 30th birthday in
England and Wales
and there's loads of reasons for that
obviously you know decline of religion
feminism
um but I think there's been an attitude
shift in gen Z but through my
experiences I don't know any women in
their early 20s who are excited about
motherhood who talk about it who
have it in their Vision I think we're
either terrified of it or we don't want
to or we're putting off as long as why
are you terrified of that
uh I don't think I am no right sorry you
said we are and I said yeah like I think
what's the source of that it's that kind
of message again from society that you
should only pursue things that make you
comfortable and happy and I think we've
kind of emphasized the personal
discomfort of it you know everything
you'll sacrifice
you know we've grown up in societies
with more comfort and convenience than
ever before so it makes sense that we
would be more risk-averse about anything
uncomfortable
um like if you go on Child free Tick
Tock it has like 780 million views and
it's
a lot mostly girls pretty much all girls
talking viscerally against motherhood uh
you know there's one that does a free
birth control Series where she just
shows you like the most horrifying
aspects of motherhood whether it's
losing sleep or your child being sick on
you all of these things
and all of the comments are just like
they don't even understand why you would
ever do that because they just think oh
it's all about personal discomfort
and to them it seems puzzling why you
would want to have children because it
just gets in the way of that so much but
I think it's kind of sad because I think
a lot of gen Z will miss out or delay
something meaningful
for their own personal discomfort so
they can live their best life
um and I think it might backfire do you
think it's part of the reason is a whole
generation which is essentially had
their brains hacked to believe that
instant gratification is the best form
of gratification and children are not
instantly gratifying a lot of the time
yeah I think yeah any of these
meaningful things that where you have to
your gratification is delayed you have
to compromise and sacrifice
I think as a whole we find those things
uh much more daunting because we've had
comfort and convenience at our
fingertips you know anything we want we
can kind of have much quicker than your
Generations did you know you'd have to
if you wanted to speak to a girl you'd
have to get the courage to do it
um if you wanted to get a job you'd have
to get the courage to go in and ask
about it you know all of these things
have been made much more convenient
which is good but then I think we've
developed this irrational fear of
things like discomfort and sacrifice and
I think that's why part of why we're
seeing
decline in motherhood marriage because
those things do come with with
compromise and discomfort
foreign